do you think advertisements period in
the united states for pharmaceutical
drugs should be banned
i think they can't be banned so it
doesn't matter what i think
okay
let's say you were a dictator and two
why can't they be banned okay uh either
answer either one
i believe i've been told by lawyers who
i trust
that the uh freedom of speech in the in
the u.s constitution
is such that you can't ban them that um
you could ban cigarettes and alcohol
which have no therapeutic use
but drugs have a therapeutic use and
they
uh advertisements about them can't be
banned let's assume that they can't be
because we know they won't be anyway
um but let's assume they can't be that
the and especially our supreme court now
is unlike would be unlikely to
take that seriously
but that's not the issue the issue is
that if drugs want us if the drug
companies want to spend their money
advertising
they should have to
have independent analysis of the message
that the viewers are left with about the
drug so that it's realistic what's the
chance the drug will help them well with
intralicity it's one out of 323. 322
people aren't going to benefit from the
cardiovascular reduction risk reduction
um
what's the true cost when when drugs
advertise that you may be able to get
this for a 25 copay or something
tens of thousands of dollars a year drug
for 25 copay what an enormous disservice
that is to misrepresent the costs of
society that should not be allowed so
you should have to
make it clear to the viewers how many
people are going to benefit what's your
chance of benefiting how does it compare
to lifestyle changes or less expensive
therapies what do you give up if you use
a less expensive therapy or gain perhaps
and how much it costs how much it costs
now that can go either way because if
you say humira costs 72 000
and it's no more effective as a
first-line drug than methotrexate which
costs 480
people might say i want the expensive
drug uh because i can get it for 25
copay um so you'd have to uh
temper that a little bit oh you mean
people are so
they don't care they don't care their
insurance is going to cover it and it's
a 25 copay but we could figure out how
to deal with that the the main point is
that
if we assume that advertisements are
going to keep going and they are
we could
require
that there be outside evaluation of the
message that reasonable unbiased viewers
take away from the ads
and the ads would have to tell the truth
about the drug
and the the truth
should have like sub-truth guard rails
meaning like the cost that we talked
about
the effects compared to things that
actually you know lifestyle changes
um
just these details very strict
guardrails of what actually has to be
specified
and i would make it against the law
to have family picnics or dogs catching
frisbees in the ads
so
you mean 95 of the ads yes
um i mean there's something dark and
authentic about those advertisements but
they see i mean i'm sure they're being
done because they work for the target
audience
you